how does a writer create conflict uh
well conflict is created by two opposing
forces so if we're talking about the
main conflict in a story right that's
the protagonist trying to pursue their
goal and then whatever sort of main
force of opposition is getting in their
way so it could be
um well it can manifest in a lot of
different ways but it's whatever that
main thing is that's stopping the
protagonist or not allowing them to
easily and quickly achieve that goal
yeah and it seems like let's say with
hustle which we've talked about earlier
the Adam Sandler movie it's a pretty
clear you know idea of what that
conflict is but if you look at let's say
Forrest Gump an older version of a movie
um it's not actually that clear there's
many things he's encountering yeah and
that's another reason that I would I
would call Forrest Gump a sort of an
advanced and advanced craft story right
because it's pretty non-traditional it's
you know you have one guy and I don't
know that I would say he has a very
clear end point that he's working toward
it's a little bit episodic we're sort of
watching him kind of go through history
different notable points in history and
kind of accidentally showing up in the
right place at the wrong time or
whatever
um so that is a that's one of those
stories that I think would be a
difficult one for a newer writer to try
to make work because
if you don't have that sort of like
standard framework of character pursuing
a goal to give you that spine and kind
of that main conflict to rely on then
you have to use other tools in your
toolkit to create enough conflict and
enough engagement to keep us invested
right to keep us engaged in the story
and sort of not checking out and turning
it off so I think Forrest Gump does that
through like you know just the sort of
novelty of the character right like he's
what's that guy going to do next like
where is he going to show up and what
what
um you know famous moment in history are
we going to show it see him pop up in so
I think that's part of the appeal of
that story and then also within within
each kind of little segment of story I
do think that there is conflict it's not
like I'm saying that it has no conflict
but I think it happens you know in sort
of
like instead of happening kind of big
picture across the whole movie if I'm
remembering it correctly it happens more
in self-contained segments and then you
also have these store these like longer
story lines of like his
um love for Jenny right his relationship
for Jenny which weaves in and out of the
other stuff that's happening if if I'm
remembering that right yeah no that's
excellent and and then if you look at
crash which I know we brought up earlier
that is like nothing but conflict yeah
which is the through line of basically
the story that ties
all the characters and different stories
together yeah so that one has so many I
think it has like three or four
intersecting storylines right and each
one has its own sort of main conflict
that we're following
um and then part of the appeal of that
too is seeing how those story lines
intersect because that's kind of the the
point of the story or the concept of it
how can goals of the protagonist and
antagonists oppose each other to create
conflict uh well there's a lot of
different ways
um
I think that you know if you look at if
you look at the movies that you like
you'll you'll probably see that they the
main conflict falls into a few different
categories
um it's not always the same from movie
to movie
um sometimes the protagonist has a goal
and the antagonist is trying to stop
them sometimes the antagonist has a goal
and the protagonist is trying to stop
them
um sometimes they both want the same
thing and so they're competing for you
know a prize or a thing that only one of
them can have
um and then sometimes they just happen
to be you know the protagonist and
antagonist are just two characters who
each have a goal that happen to conflict
with each other so they're getting in
each other's way those are kind of the
ones that I've noticed are the are the
most common versions of that
sure and then did we go back to
bridesmaids that there is it seems like
all of them have a common goal which is
to be accepted amongst their peer group
yeah well if we're talking about the
story goal the more sort of like plot
specific
um thing that the protagonist is trying
to achieve
so it's actually
um the antagonist is Helen which is the
The Rose Burn character right and she
wants to take over our protagonist's
friendship so she's the the Rival for
this best friendship right that Annie
our protagonist has her lifelong best
friend
um so when Annie discovers that
about the Helen character that's when
she forms her goal to stop the
antagonist right so it's just sort of
you know it's a little bit of um it
might sound very technical or very like
Theory heavy but I think these are just
tools that help you understand your own
story and understand how your particular
story works so it's not that I'm I
certainly don't mean that you have four
different types of conflict and you have
to use one of them I think if you you
know if you've come up with an idea that
you're trying to develop
trying to look at it through these four
types of conflict right or these four
kind of like conflict Dynamics
if you can see that your conflict falls
into one of those categories it just
helps you understand like oh okay so if
mine is like this then that means you
know it gives you it gives you a little
bit of guidance in terms of okay so that
means the antagonist has to come up with
their goal first so that then the
protagonist can find out about it and
form her story goal right and that gives
you a little bit of guidance in terms of
like okay so that's the order that
things need to happen in so I can break
down the plot of my movie that way and
it helps you write it so right and it
seems like in some films the antagonist
doesn't really turn out to be the
antagonist at all or maybe that's just
how I'm seeing it and then others it's
clearly that was the antagonist and they
were defeated or they they win whatever
way so Silence of the Lambs we know that
definitely he's the antagonist but in in
Bridesmaids it's kind of not you know
maybe Helen is not totally it's just
that they both had their own sort of
needs and they were just getting in the
way yeah and I think that that you can
look at that too as being like
appropriate to the tone or the style of
what you're writing right because it
might have felt weird if Helen that
antagonist was you know had seriously
kind of like evil designs on Annie
and all that stuff right so the humor in
that keeps it you know that that's also
a guide in terms of like what types of
conflict are going to work in this
um so those two characters you probably
have a little bit more empathy for uh
for Helen than you do for Buffalo Bill
you'd even though you learn why he's
doing what he's doing uh Helen is more
of a real character and the comedy comes
from you know the these kind of like
wacky situations that our protagonist
gets herself into you know sure and we
look at maybe Helen it's more about
vanity and sort of serving her own ego
and yeah but but then you find out that
actually she's very empty and so it's
not it's you feel for her in the end
yeah you want to hate her and then you
realize I don't actually hate you yeah
they do a good job actually of revealing
that she is not sort of the I mean she
is sort of shallow and and focused on
status and and all that through the
movie but they do reveal that she has a
you know an emotional need of her own
she's lonely and she's in an
unfulfilling marriage and so you kind of
end up growing I think to at least feel
for her if not like her more by the end
and she's still the you know when we're
talking about protagonist and
antagonists we're really just talking
about like the mechanics of the story
not necessarily that she needs to feel
like a villain or like a you know an
evil character or even that you can't
like her you know you can like the
character who is the sort of
antagonistic Force we're just talking
about the the way the elements of the
story work together to kind of you know
create that that
um story engine or that that
um spine of the story that we were
talking about earlier
I think we spoke about this briefly in
our last interview but what are the four
common ways characters challenge
protagonists oh
um well I usually think about that in
terms of like the supporting characters
that are sort of around you know the
protagonist and again you know these are
not not limited to four there certainly
could be many other ways but I think
that these are the patterns that I've
noticed
um a lot of times the supporting
characters will sort of help the
protagonist through conflict right like
they create some sort of conflict with
the protagonist
um but that conflict or that pain that
they're bringing into the protagonist's
life is one of those sort of forcing
um mechanisms that that force that
protagonist to grow and learn the lesson
that they need to learn right
um so the four that I've noticed are
like um I think I call them like
aspirational models so giving your
conflict or sorry giving your
protagonist
um
a a model of what they would like to do
or like to achieve or like to be and
that can create conflict because it you
know creates a situation where your
protagonist is unhappy with where they
are and they're striving for more
um there's also the cautionary tale so
creating you know creating it's almost
the opposite of the of the other one
where
um it's showing your protagonist what
could happen if they continue down the
road that they're on right so this is
you know sort of like that that side
character in and this is such a minor
minor role but in Crazy Stupid Love that
sad divorced dad at the bar right like
that's the cautionary tale he does not
want to become that guy so he's going to
continue on
striving to be the womanizer that he's
being groomed to be because it's that
that cautionary tale
um it's a reminder to him
um and then there's also uh I forget
what I've labeled them but um you have
sort of the uh Mentor character or the
person that helps your character learn
that they're capable or they have it in
them to do the thing that they're trying
to do
and that doesn't always have to be you
know a nice Mentor it can be someone who
pushes through tough love or through
conflict through challenging your
character but it's but the ultimate
effect is that it's forcing them to grow
and to accept that they are strong
enough capable enough smart enough
whatever
um and then what's the fourth one
actually oh so a new world view oh yeah
so that's challenging the way your
protagonist sees the world right so
um a lot of times the transformation
that your character goes through is is a
is an it starts internally and then it
manifests externally so sometimes
there's a supporting character that
demonstrates the new way of thinking
that maybe ultimately your character
will adopt or it challenges their own
way of thinking enough that they grow
and they make that change that they need
to make to sort of have a new attitude
about the world or A New Perspective a
new life philosophy that that was the
sort of the point of the story right
that was the growth that they needed at
the beginning
yeah so I think in Bridesmaids is
Melissa McCarthy that one scene yeah
that's so great so she kind of gives her
a you know kick in the pants
um and and does it in a sort of a sweet
tough love way yeah yeah that's a great
scene so she comes in and she's like
what did she say it's something like you
know the world isn't gonna like hand it
to you you have to go out there and take
it the world's telling you it's here to
be taken or something like that I can't
remember the exact words but but yeah
she she gives her that it's very funny
but it's also uh the exact sort of like
tough love message that Annie needs at
that point sure and she's literally on
the couch yeah you know not just
metaphorically only touch she's on the
couch feeling sorry for herself and
she's kind of I think she picks her up
doesn't she even throw her over her
shoulder or something but yeah and then
with hustle I can't really remember I
feel like there were Mentor characters
that were helping
um the Adam Sandler character yeah well
what's interesting I think in Hustle is
that um you know you don't have to have
a I guess sort of like archetypal Mentor
for this to for this like sort of role
to come into play
um any character yeah any supporting
character that sort of helps your
protagonist along that you know Arc of
growth right can can fill any of these
roles so what's great about hustle is
those two guys it's really their
relationship they learn from each other
you know so even though they're not like
you know technically what I would call
like a mentor to each other that's not
kind of their role throughout the whole
movie maybe in terms of helping each of
them grow and and sort of get to the
point that they need to be in order to
succeed in the movie they do learn from
each other like the basketball player
learns that you know there's some people
you can rely on you can actually depend
on someone they're going to come through
for you uh and I kind of forget what
Adam Sandler learns from the basketball
player but it's you know I think it's
complementary to that right it's like
um
if you keep trying keep working you can
like you know succeed and not let people
down or something like that so
um talking about that Melissa McCarthy
character quick quick point about that
what's great about that character is
that that speech she gives right to
Annie doesn't come out of the blue so
that was the last thing I wanted to
mention about her was that that
character has that world view from the
beginning so she Melissa McCarthy has
that sort of attitude about you go out
and you grab life you you do it you take
what you want or you take the kind of
life you want you know you don't sit
back you don't sit on the couch and like
let it pass you by if you want something
you go out and you try for it if you
fail no big deal if you look like a fool
no big deal but you you have to try in
order to get what you want and so I
think if you know the bad version of
that relationship and that movie would
have been if Melissa McCarthy was just a
nice bridesmaid who came along at the
right moment in the end to tell Annie
what she needed to know right that would
have felt sort of unearned and tacked on
but because we saw that you know we
didn't know where that was going from
the beginning but we saw that that
Melissa McCarthy character was that
person all the way through so when she
delivers that message to Annie right
when she needs it it makes sense it
feels emotionally true you know sure
sure and just going back to hustle real
quick it seems like also too they both
respect each other because they know
their families are very important to
them yeah and so I think they both have
sort of earned that
um and they become almost mentors to
each other yeah in some ways yeah I
think they do they they sort of because
they each go into it I think with
certain preconceived notions about the
other right like our basketball player
thinks that Adam Sandler is just this
Rich American who can kind of like you
know he's got the the wallet of the the
team behind him and he can do whatever
and over time they learn they kind of
learn how desperate each one is but they
learn what's really motivating each of
them and they bond over that right
because they each have a family to like
you said each have a family to support
they learn that they each are kind of
like on their you know this is this is
it this is is the last chance that they
have to kind of like make this big thing
happen so as those you know truths are
revealed about each of them it bonds
them it makes them grow closer which
helps that sort of like partnership and
help helps them accomplish the thing
yeah